here we go film theory
yeah what's up guys we're gonna watch
from film theorist
film theory why godzilla wins okay
this is a long one i mean we did a video
of who we thought would win
really went to bat for like very
specific why we think godzilla went i
can't remember which video it was
i really broke down how i think the
fight including the fight with
mechagodzilla would go down and also uh
we did do a trailer reaction recently
that was up on a bunch of trailer sites
this mechagodzilla and i we got a
copyright strike
from warner brothers down entirely those
trailer sites got copyright strikes
other reactors got copyright strikes so
it must have been a leaked trailer
that other trailer sites were like screw
it put it up i'm excited to see what the
film theaters have to say and i'm glad
they're already on
our side that's right that's right this
is credibility for us
your apes gonna fall your hairy cheeks
are gonna get smacked
but it's gonna be exciting i'm so
excited to see kong because everyone has
fun you know
okay guys you are never gonna believe
this i i know godzilla versus kong is
coming out in a few weeks but i managed
to get myself an
early copy of the movie or should i say
i managed to find a leaked bootleg copy
that someone is willing to sell me on
the internet
all right let's looks a little beat up i
thought the title was different maybe
that was just an early draft anyway
let's check this thing out
odd choice feels a bit low-fi but maybe
they were looking for something
different
okay drop it i think i'm the dub version
yes i haven't seen the dub
this is the original godzilla versus
king kong
i yep okay
hey don't knock it
i love this gotta say i don't hate it
i miss popcorn
cool hello internet welcome to film
theory the show that's more fun than a
beautiful
giant prehistoric cryptids you know it's
been a tough couple of years for
legendary pictures as big budget monster
verse franchise
after audiences got so annoyed at
godzilla not showing up for more than a
few minutes of his eyes
by not showing up at all for his
significantly more exciting sequel king
of the monsters in 2019
boom get dunked on godzilla the only
thing that's reliably able to take you
down is poor box office earnings
fortunately for godzilla and company
though the studio was already well into
production on the next movie at that
point
but then world events shut down theaters
and now only by the grace of our
corporate masters at at
warner brothers can we finally see
godzilla vs kong the way any iconic
summer blockbuster battle between two
400 foot monsters was meant to be
watched two and a half inches high
this is a movie that's everybody raising
a bunch of questions why are they
fighting
when did kong get so much bigger why
didn't this happen years ago alongside
civil war and batman v superman
side note is this whole thing gonna get
resolved by both of them knowing someone
named mothra mothra
why did you say that name but we all
know what the big question is in these
sorts of movies who is gonna win
well if you know the channel you know
that we're gonna do our darndest to
answer this one early
and if you don't know the channel
consider subscribing for mind-blowing
theories each and every week that'll
make you look smart in front of all your
friends now then let's start answering
our question by having a look at both of
our competitors
according to the monsterverse canon this
incarnation of godzilla
is 393 feet tall or about 120 meters
not counting the additional 189 feet or
57.6 meters of his tail
and he did not know that approximately
99
634 tons making him unquestionably the
largest version of godzilla ever
depicted in live action
by contrast kong was only a hundred and
four feet tall
he was just a baby in scotland him in
kong skull island which is
pretty big but only a fourth of
godzilla's side
it seems like he's gotten himself a lot
bigger considering that in the new
movie's trailer they stand next to each
other on some aircraft carriers and
kong is at godzilla's eye level even
taller man looking at this scene just
makes me think the real winner of this
battle is any boat able to float while
two hunters
duke it out on the deck now knowing
these rough statistics we can use
science to see which creature is going
to pack a bigger punch oh here we go
that's what godzilla's heat ray weapon
does
science best temperature estimate look
at overall differences between the
mammalian brain and the reptile brain to
see whose strategy
oh my god there's one major problem with
all of that if i'm using science well
science says that both these creatures
would lose because they can't possibly
exist in the first place you know those
fun ruining laws of science
say explosions in space or sound in
space or
literally everything to do with space
giant monster movies tend to smack head
first and all those fun ruining laws of
science mainly physics problems like the
square cube law that's the mathematical
principle discovered by galileo in 1638
that says
that mass increases at a faster rate
than size
basically as area squares mass cubes
and the this of a muscle or bone is
roughly the function of its area but
weight is a function of volume so let's
say you double a monkey's height while
keeping it the same shape you wind up
with four times the muscle power
moving eight times the mass that as
you might imagine an organism can only
scale up a certain amount before all the
other forces of physics and
thermodynamics cause it to collapse in
on itself
neither kong nor godzilla would be able
to grow to their respective
sizes if they existed at that size
gravity would break their bones
if their bones were somehow strong
enough gravity would pull the flesh and
organs
off those bones if their entire bodies
were strong enough they'd collapse
into the earth itself and even if you
negated those issues it is
mathematically inconceivable that kong
would consume enough nutrients and water
to sustain himself each and every day
so well i'd love to science my way into
an answer for this one the suspension of
disbelief here is so extreme that you
need like a wizard or a fairy or some
level of literal
magic to even approach working this out
did you guys know that mad pal was
actually one of the original hired
screenwriters but he created too many
problems in the writing room
when he was trying to logically map out
exactly how we got to this point and who
could win
and then he brought in science into the
equation and was eventually fired for
being too difficult to work with there
goes your screenwriting career
god damn they should only be 50 feet
tall each
that's not enough it would be actually
great is if you watch this movie you're
like oh my god they factored in science
i would and both of them step onto the
battlefield and then just
implode into a massive bones and muscles
these human characters who are apex
monarch who are scientist characters
actually use
real science fortunately for us that's
exactly what we have
see the japanese kaiju genre and this
monster verse in particular has
really leaned into the mishmash of
atomic age sci-fi
gothic mad science and straight-up
folklore to justify the handwavium it
takes to get onto the stompy stompy sure
most of the friends and foes of godzilla
gamera and the rest are supposed to be
dinosaurs mutations or aliens from outer
space but more than a few are also
identified as legendary supernatural
creatures
demons spirits even literal gods by the
legend
godzilla
they're true
in fact godzilla gets his name in the
original 1954 movie from local legend
about a sea monster so even in his
earliest appearance he's equal parts
regional folklore and atomic monster and
that mix has persisted throughout all of
his incarnations
the 1990s japanese reboot series retcon
godzilla's origin to be a normal
dinosaur who protected japanese soldiers
stationed on an island in world war
ii but he's also a karmic force
punishing the many saved for spending
their lives in pursuit of
capitalist greed sir you must leave your
office
if godzilla only knew how to monetize
himself he'd understand
if he understood the power of his brand
but the dinosaur saved us all and all of
that prosperity i built
now being destroyed by the same dinosaur
at this moment you guys know what the
double do about it
absolutely very ironic don't you think
corporate bastards
[Music]
wow that is uh burn cobra for a movie
with a guy in a rubber dinosaur suit
then a decade later the movie godzilla
mothra and king ghidorah giant monsters
all-out attacks
definitely a mouthful featured an even
scarier magical godzilla who was made
sorting out no really virgin godzilla is
inhabited by the angry souls of
everyone who was killed in the pacific
during world war ii and he's come to
stop japan
into rubble as punishment for them
joining the war in the first place
each and every time in these movies i
hope we get this one
comic monster after all but more so the
stories are resolved via folklore king
kong is largely the same way in the
original 1933 film he's a god who
demands sacrifices from skull island's
indigenous people and again in the
original king kong vs godzilla from 1962
do you mean incomparable uncomfortable
just makes it seem like king kong has a
mild case of jock itch
anyway time and again we see these
creeps
you can't have folklore without the lore
bit
and yes the monster verse make sure to
check that box too
calms god on the island but the devils
live below us
what are they called skull crawlers why
sound cool that sounds neat and this is
where we're gonna be able to find our
answer
in battles between gods it's not a
question of science it's a question of
religion and it's here that oh
interesting interesting
oh all right maybe maybe not that weird
is he going
to go down the monster versus godzilla
origin is tied very strongly to what's
called a scene
[Music]
prior to all of known history there was
an advanced human civilization with a
shared language and culture that
fell somehow and whose scattered
population subsequently founded all the
different human societies that come
later
these are your classic legends like
atlantis and the tower of babel
and the theory is meant to explain how
societies that never met somehow have
weird similarities like why all the
old-timey cultures were so into building
pyramids why the
same monsters exist in the mythology of
all corners of the earth and why
every culture somehow inexplicably loves
minecraft looks egyptian
a roman now this is something different
this is way older now no legitimate
historian really
takes this theory seriously but it's
treated as real in this latest
incarnation of the monster burst
i already think how far are we
9 minutes and 21 seconds more thought
has been put
into the science and philosophy of
godzilla versus [ __ ]
then and you know what's gonna be
in the actual whole movie i'm not saying
it's not there i'm just saying
it seems like it's the bible of all this
is so much more intricate here that i
think will be put on display in the
actual movie this is maybe probably get
like a few lines yeah emotes
making a compelling case for swapping
out the human characters and just
putting in matpat this is making a
compelling case to make it a television
series
and one of the hallmarks of this theory
is that many ancient religions have a
common theme of the new gods sweeping in
to overthrow the old and ugly false gods
that came before
like zeus and the olympians defeating
the titans or the viking gods against
the frost giants
in fact even some ancient versions of
the book of genesis described noah's
flood as happening to destroy half-human
half-angel giants called nephilim who
tried to usurp the hebrew god
these proto-civilization ideas also tend
to come bundled with hollow earth
theories
in which the old gods or losing
civilization is then forced to retreat
underground now in the movies the
character dr serzawa has a film theory
of his own based on all of this
it's not just a cute nickname godzilla
and all his big buddies are
literally the titans as in the original
true gods of this fallen
proto-civilization
and since he is a very serious scientist
with a very very silly theory in a
godzilla movie he turns out to be
exactly right
these are not monsters they are animals
rising to reclaim a wall that was once
theirs but wait if godzilla is a titan
and titans are the old gods who
generally
lose and get driven underground in all
the creation myths and kong
is also a god by his people and he lives
on the surface
and his main possibly only job on skull
island was beating up lizards that come
up from the underground then godzilla
versus kong
isn't just a title fight it's a rematch
and the movie is
the first implies that this fight has
happened before
and the trailer for the new movie
features a lot of talk about a war
in the past tense the myths are real
there was a war
given everything that we just talked
about we know who won the battle the
first time
kong he's the one on the surface he's
the one retreating
he has beaten godzilla so godzilla is
coming into this thing with a loss
already on the board does that thereby
mean that kong is the favorite to win
well yeah actually it fits with the
mythology and it fits narratively given
the fact that godzilla just had a
massive victory in king of the monsters
okay you know i'm liking this so far
because
the trailers have been pitching kong as
the underdog even though i feel like
godzilla's gonna win ultimately they've
been pitching kong as the underdog
in the story itself if kong actually has
won before because a lot of the theories
have actually been that older
generations of godzilla and older
generations of kong are the ones that
have duked it out but if kong has
already won
before this iteration then that will
make godzilla the underdog in this
situation and then we can get flashbacks
to a fight where they were much
tinier where they were best friends in
the school yard yeah
this understanding
he is due for a loss but i think our
biggest proof for what's actually going
to happen in this movie comes from the
original king kong versus godzilla
here we go in 1962. you see friends it's
easy to overlook amidst all the urban
destruction but these sorts of crossover
movies are like the hype house of cinema
we get a bunch of
loud monsters together for a collab so
that they can all get more
popular and this was true in that first
movie back in 1962
kong was the much more well-known and
popular monster godzilla had
only appeared in two movies before that
number two
we know about in fact king kong vs
godzilla only happened because a super
shady
hollywood producer em borrowed an
incomplete production concept
called king kong vs frankenstein and
then ran off to japan to produce a
different unapproved version using
godzilla instead of frank by the time
the studios back in the us who actually
owned
kong caught wind of this and took him
back king kong versus godzilla was
already a gigantic worldwide hit
and godzilla oh no oh wow company toho
cranking out godzilla sequels and
has never really stopped since but in
the movie neither one
actually loses godzilla kind of loses
because he disappears and kong is the
one seen swimming off into the sunset
but neither one is officially a loser
here
the director did say uh director or
president of toho one of them yeah i
think he was the president of touhou oh
yeah
did say that kong was the winner in that
movie flat out said it
do your research yeah that pal gives
your team is
lazy you guys suck the editing and the
researching
my god you need to spend a little less
time editing a little more time
reading watch right when we hit play
it's gonna be like even though the
president's total
damage and you see friends that is where
this whole thing starts coming together
you see the real win for the studio here
isn't about who wins
it's that neither monster loses losing
implies that one fan base is right and
one fan base is wrong one set of merch
is cooler than the other one franchise
continues on successfully while the
other kind of dies because it lost in
the last one
and the way you avoid that situation is
to split the difference
godzilla villains so the warring
factions can team up or
just render the verdict money enough
that no one knows who actually won or
lost i mean i was joking about it before
but batman v superman couldn't wait to
tell you that doomsday was the real big
bad in that movie and superman doesn't
die by batman's hand
he does it to himself in a heroic
sacrifice for mankind he still loses the
fight
that zemo was manipulating them all the
whole time causing everyone to forget
that the civil war between captain
america and iron man didn't
really have a clear-cut winner even
twilight denied its fans a decisive team
and
well i mean captain america around
captain america won the fight the fight
between them captain america what
and in batman v superman batman won that
fight absolutely
it's pretty clear who won the fights in
those even twilight denied its fans a
decisive team edward versus team jacobs
showdown in favor of them teaming up
against the new challenger the evil
vampire legion which ended up being
all a dream anyway that was the best one
ever i guess
and of course the real villain of the
ring versus the grudge turned out to be
whoever decided we needed the ring
versus the garage
seriously neither one wins out in that
case either they also join forces
this also would coincide with the lore
for the movies it's easy to overlook but
technically both monsters are heroes
kong protects our heroes on skull island
godzilla protects the world from all the
awakened titans they are both
good guys here heck there's even this
line about godzilla and king of the
monsters
he fought for us died for us he is not
only proof that co-existence is possible
exactly
is the key to it so one losing here just
doesn't make a lot of sense and that's
why ladies and gentlemen here's my real
prediction
in the trailer for godzilla vs kong we
hear this line godzilla's out there and
he's hurting people and we don't know
why which implies that he's been
behaving himself since last time and now
something weird is happening well in
traditional godzilla movie lore if
godzilla ain't acting like himself
because he's not himself that's right we
have ourselves a new
challenger in the ring and his name is
i don't think they listen to the
to the filmmakers multiple different
areas of the franchise
almost always as either a remote
controlled or piloted fighting robot and
always as one of the real godzilla's
deadliest opponents and while he's
usually pretty hard to miss
being all hundreds of feet tall and
shiny in his first appearance in 1974's
godzilla vs mechagodzilla he spends the
first half of the film wearing
fake skin to disguise himself as the
real
thing so could it be that in some or
even all of the scenes that we've seen
in the trailer thus far we're getting
misdirected and
kong is actually fighting a giant robot
wearing a godzilla suit
a lot of eagle-eyed monster fans have
noticed some tiny spots in the trailer
notice the godzilla-shaped creature on
the computer monitor but definitely a
robot
back there this head in the building
rubble where they think they can see
godzilla's mechanical doppelganger
hiding in plain sight and while we
haven't seen giant mecha in the monster
verse yet we have seen both monarch
and alan jonah the eco-terrorist baddie
throughout the monster versus collecting
titan body parts as plot points
monarch's secret
base had a muto skull built into its
centerpiece and a post-credits scene and
king of the monsters featured jonah
collecting king ghidorah's severed head
why would that matter well recently
unembargoed set reports have described
that head
as being a prop in the new film but now
quote fused with technology
and historically both mechagodora and
mechagodzilla have been depicted
as human piloted cyborgs built out of
the bodies of deceased kaiju this would
allow us to see kong battle
a godzilla team up with the real
godzilla and leave both of these monster
heroes as winners to continue their
franchises as victors
now that is what i would call a twist so
there you have it folks
kong and godzilla will meet and you will
see that i mean he knows the filmmakers
thing
exactly but they they said like
mechagodzilla is driving godzilla crazy
or whatever
yeah all right maybe not that one's just
silly but oh my god
next theory and remember to atomic
breath that subscribe button my friends
like i said before this is the channel
that gives you a lot of cool stuff to
talk about when it comes to movies tv
and youtube with all your friends so be
the first on your blog to come up with
these theories find new shows or movies
that might be interesting for you to
watch so across the board it is a kaiju
sized good decision to subscribe to this
channel and by the way if you missed my
first kong skull island theory where i
did predict all this hollow earth stuff
that one is on screen right now
totally called it i'll see you all next
week
nice great job appreciate you i mean as
always i really really like the video a
lot
love it and uh the script is hilarious
the theories are solid
and science science the editing the
religious philosophy
yeah all great i do think though that
its ending moments are
kind of already disproved though with
yeah with the recent interview that came
out
on comicbook.com from the filmmakers who
pretty much made it clear
mechagodzilla is a separate entity that
there will be godzilla
real godzilla versus the real kong they
have mechagodzilla built by apex
with king ghidorah's head so all that is
true but this whole thing with
godzilla in disguise kong thinks he's
fighting the real
godzilla but he's really fighting
mechagodzilla yeah
that's already been disproved hasn't it
it seems like i mean unless they choose
to incorporate that plot element in a
slightly different way but the
sense i got from that quote was that
yeah mechagodzilla will be a well
established outside force in some degree
yeah not so much a big reveal like oh
damn because i feel like at that point
if he was going to be godzilla under uh
or mechagodzilla under his skin
they would want to deflect from that as
much as possible you know yeah
so i i think that's already been
disproved by the filmmakers themselves
you know there are things that we
brought up in our previous videos so you
guys can go watch i'm sure i'll link
them like
how with the short super summery version
you know toho said that kong won
in the first king kong vs godzilla movie
now at days of tahoe wants to continue
their partnership with legendary
pitchers and keep the godzilla franchise
alive and especially with
who godzilla is now at the time when
godzilla was viewed as
primarily a villain now he's much more
glorified i don't think toho would let
godzilla be the loser in the fight here
and i feel like that's one of the main
reasons why
there's also like physicality things
godzilla survives like nuclear they
literally
nuked him in the last like twice they
knew timmy you know
yeah plus i mean i could imagine this
setting up uh
franchise possibilities where it's like
you have godzilla on main earth you have
kong do stuff in the hollow earth and
there you go you got parallel worlds
that can cross over whatever you want
with the fight between godzilla and kong
i think godzilla will win the fight and
i think mecha godzilla will show up
and then godzilla might get like knocked
down
by mecha godzilla and then kong will
step in and take down mechagodzilla yeah
and then that's how kong gets a victory
and
yeah yeah exactly and then it's like we
cool now dawg
that's where i think it's gonna go this
is my personal theory but you guys can
watch those other videos
other than that you know i like the idea
of honing in a little bit more on the
philosophical side and the religious
aspect to it that's something that
hasn't really been brought up
that much it is in there with the uh
sarah zawa kamatanabe character it's
brought up a lot in there
and through some other characters in the
lore as well and they also do explain in
kong skull island john c reilly has a
line in there that says that he still
hear what he says
something that implies that he's still
young and he's still growing as it
stands you know
in a day it all goes to support what i
want
goes back to team godzilla and i
definitely learned a lot about an
additional godzilla lore as well
yeah and a good amount about the real
natural world
yeah damn all right guys if you haven't
done so already subscribe to film theory
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to us
we'll be sure to cover more godzilla
versus kong down the road last but not
least
daniel the gallacher i hope you're doing
well
over in scotland you know what this
world needs though
is if there was a monster attack i would
want you to be the protagonist in that
movie if we were in a kaiju world think
of it
well-meaning pharmacist daniel gallacher
forced
to rely upon how could you do it by
being a medic instead of being some kind
of military guy with a bunch of
action skills kicking ass we've seen
that a million times before
you could be a character out in the
streets help and heal people
after the destruction that these badass
monsters
inevitably cause if they're insured yeah
if you're not insured
check everyone's insurance on the
streets before you start tending to them
because you know money is still the most
important part of the ecosystem like we
discussed in the video with godzilla and
branding and whatnot so
make sure pharmacists and scottish
that's all we got
absolutely yeah much love buddy
[Music]